alors pour monsieur madame fouillot pour
monsieur madame grégory d'aval c'est
très dur parce que finalement trois mois
ils ont perdu l'an filles dans des
conditions atroces que vous connaissez
mes sons perdus également leur chambre
qui était qui avait toute sa place dans
leur famille est aujourd'hui autour de
la table familiale bay à 2 à 7 de moins
c'est comme si cette élection en voiture
avec deux morts il y en a une qui est
définitivement retranché la communauté
des vivants
et puis on a un autre qui va être emmuré
vivant certainement pour un certain
nombre d'années dans le respect de la
présomption d'innocence et dans le
respect la décision sera mené en finale
à prendre un coup d'assises de ce
département
alors perdre deux êtres chers sous des
régimes différents en trois mois
plus la notion de trahison du relm en
absolu qui ne le peuvent qu
inévitablement à voir au fond du coeur
c'est beaucoup pour des braves gens qui
avaient une vie je dirais une vie
tranquille et cadré et puis et puis le
pour en finir sur ce premier j'irai sur
ce premier sujet il va falloir aller
parce que cette propres de l'instruction
il va falloir encaissé révélation ce
révélations dans le cadre d'autres
aveugles passera monsieur d'aval je n'en
doute pas parce que est dans le flou
dans le profond respect du secret
d'instruction qui me lie en tant qu
auxiliaire de justice toute personne qui
aura accès ce dossier où qui a déjà eu
accès à ce dossier
c'est qu'actuellement les amène le sud
aval sont très loin des réalités
objectives
moi je suis très satisfait qu'il ait
commencé à vous et pour mes clients
parce que c'est un réconfort et pour lui
parce que c'est le chemin de la
construction et pour la vérité tout
court et la vérité judiciaire mais il ya
encore naturellement beaucoup beaucoup
de chemin à parcourir pour jonathan
d'aval pour que ces déclarations
coïncident parfaitement avec la réalité
des faits tels qu objectivement démontre
au dossier
alors on en avait parlé parce que c'est
une question qui m'avait traversé
l'esprit dès le début d'automne à tana
d'ailleurs assez parlé librement tout au
début aux enquêteurs leur sentiment
c'est que le fonctionnement de ce couple
était un fonctionnement assez normal
c'est-à-dire qu'il pouvait y avoir des
hauts et des bas que parfois alexia
comme on dire du fait notamment de vue
désir maternité et du traitement du
retard dans cette maternité pouvait on
va dire ne pas toujours être facile mais
ils n'avaient rien remarqué je leur
avais posé plusieurs fois la question il
n'avait rien remarqué de symptomatique
donc pour eux n'ont pas de violence de
la part de johnatan pas de violence
peut-être parfois verbal à mouthe trop
une réflexion mal tourné mais rien pour
eux d'un symptomatique de symptomatique
qui aurait permis de penser un instant
que johnatan aurait pu passer aux actes
et qu'ils ont fait en danger ça va de
soi donc un fonctionnement d'un jeune
couple normale au bout de dix ans de
mariage concubinage qui est un peu en
crise parce qu'on attend on voudra un
bébé et que ça traîne mais sans plus
l'histoire banale
je sais pas je les ai pas eus après les
écoutez sur la seconde chaîne de vos
confrères ou ici représentée ce qualimed
chauffeur j'ai pas eu leurs réactions
après parce qu'il était déjà forte à
aucun moment faut laisser un peu digéré
les choses et j'en appelle plus après 23
heures
on verra ça aujourd'hui comment qu'est
ce qu'ils pensent de st alors pour bien
connaître mercure dorfer pour qui j'ai
le plus profonde amitié estime c'est
quelqu'un de très réaliste et de très
franc jeu s'il dit ça ce n'est pas comme
certains nos confrères un effet de
manche en effet de bluff un effet chez
pas quoi pour scandalisé le ministre du
droit des droits des femmes ce matin son
échelle c'est eux s'ils le disent et non
seulement qu'ils le pensent mais qui le
sait alors je me garderai bien à ce
stade là de confirmer ou d'infirmer
j'entends ce qu'il a dit et connaissant
le personnage je ne fais pas de raison
d'en plaît de dire c'est pas vrai c'est
difficile à entendre
c'est difficile à entendre comme c'est
difficile à comprendre qu'un brave
garçon comme johnatan d'aval si parfait
vous rappeler cette phrase qui m'obsède
ou client monsieur fouillot le papa
d'alexia dire à la basilique au monde
l'enterrement je souhaite à toutes les
jeunes femmes qui sont ici présents
devant un agent bros idéal que jonathan
donc c'est aussi difficile de comprendre
jonathan d'aval que d'admettre que
parfois le
la personne battus soit pas celle qu'on
attend dans ces dossiers là je dirai
tout est difficile parce que la ridt la
réalité humaine et donc la réalité
criminelle est souvent très complexes
johnatan il n'a pas le profil d'un tueur
et pourtant alors ça j'ai entendu j'ai
écouté ce cas les médecins dans leur
sujet et j'ai cru comprendre ou savoir
que dans le cadre du désir de maternité
alexia prenait des médicaments et j'ai
cru comprendre également que parmi ces
médicaments pour le je suppose la
fertilité contre l'infertilité mais
enfin dans le cas de la maternité qui
n'arrivent pas s'est aussi rapidement
qu'on le souhaitait certaines classes de
médicaments était connu pour avoir des
effets secondaires en termes de sautes
d'humeur ou en termes de piques d'humeur
ou en termes le terme au vam échapper
aux ailes retrouver je ne viens pas mais
quand des personnes ont des troubles de
personnalité peuvent être changeantes on
noterait rapidement oui mais voilà
exactement bipolarité partiel ou des
choses comme ça c'est peut-être pas le
bon terme et peu pouvaient avoir des
accès on va dire d'humeur plus dur à
supporter mais liés à cette case mega
man il paraît que c'est quelque chose
d'assez connu un essai de ces
médicaments des médicaments que l'on
prend pour les cas d'infertilité ou pour
favoriser maternité sachant qu alex est
a priori était prenait un traitement
avec ce type de médicaments après je
suis pas docteur en pharmacologie
la défense personnalités finalement
écrasant c'est toujours difficile quand
on ne connaît pas les gens et encore
moins leur intimité de se prononcer moi
ce que je là ce que je dis c'est très
subjectif on conçoit sapin grand intérêt
vous savez comme moi dans certains
couples
les rapports sont égalitaires il y en a
d'autres ont dit populairement c'est
l'homme qui porte la culotte c'est
plutôt la femme qui porte la culotte
là je pense qu'il ya pas besoin de se
persuader beaucoup pour voir que dans ce
couple johnatan à une personnalité
beaucoup plus effacé beaucoup plus
timide et qu'alexia était assez
dominante tout simplement être une fille
énergique ce portier battant deux
engagés et caetera et que lui était
certainement en retrait alors c'est pas
parce que vous êtes entré il est marié
qu'une femme battante que vous êtes sous
emprise ou que vous êtes persécuté
donc ça mérite la mort ont nommé la
corde mais c'est certainement elle qui
avait la porte la personnalité et
françois roussely sur la plus forte du
couple s'adonnait engendré justement des
tensions au sein du coup sa personnalité
dominante certainement mais comme dans
tout court qui fonctionne comme ça c'est
à dire au moins un tiers voire la moitié
des couples alors maintenant voilà
maintenant c'est le rebond sur les
interrogations mais je leur ai dit qu'on
a laissé un tout petit peu de ton temps
gérer quand le palais de besançon ne
sera plus en ébullition et que le
cabinet de monsieur gagnent laitiers
juge d'instruction a retrouvé son calme
habituel
j'irai voir le dossier dès le début de
la semaine prochaine et on aura les
réponses à nos questions
parce que maintenant actuellement les
questions séoul at il tué je suppose
probablement domicile conjugal quand
l'at il tuée exactement pourquoi est
elle en pull jaune 2 alors qu'elle n'est
pas partie
est-ce qu'elle a souffert est ce qu'elle
est mort sur le coup et c est ce qu il
l'a brûlée
si c'est pas lui qui sait voilà enfin là
maintenant ce qu'ils veulent savoir
et c'est pas la curiosité malsaine
ou du voyeurisme avoir un déroulé précis
et complet la dernière nuit de la
dernière nuit de l'excellence qui est
tout à fait légitime mais ça on va le
savoir dossier simplement plus un peu
particulier a balayé la série
alors encore une fois où l'on sait
juillet par le secret d'instruction mais
je dis simplement que les aveux de
monsieur navale dont je me réjouis pour
tout le monde en particulier pour mes
clients sont un début sur le chemin de
la vérité est qu'il faudra je le
souhaite pour lui aussi non d'autres
aveux qui se rapproche davantage des
réalités objectives qui sont dans le
dossier et notamment dans les pièces
musicales incendie vous savez qu'il
existe des mécanismes de thau combustion
mais là on n'est pas dans ce cas de
figure
donc comme on n'est pas dans un cas
d'autres solutions soit c'est monsieur
naval qui a brûlé partiellement le corps
soit ils accomplissent mais il n'y a pas
à la pour le coup la réponse est binaire
il n'y a pas d'autre solution
ou c'est lui probable j'en sais rien
présomption d'innocence ou c'est pas lui
possible mais alors quelqu'un a fait
bruit essaye le ciel des éléments pour
être l'idée
à ma connaissance pas spécialement mais
je pense aussi
moi j'essaye toujours de me mettre à la
place des personnes qui ont commis des
choses très graves séquelles 4 johnatan
on ne peut pas lui reprocher à ce stade
là de ne pas reconnaître la
carbonisation si c'est lui parce que
c'est trop c'est trop
n'oubliez pas que n'oubliez pas qu'il a
une profonde affection pour mes clients
sincère et réciproque
il reconnaît enfin il a commis des
choses atroces qu'il a masqué n'en
parlera peut-être il reconnaît en fin de
garde à vue avoir donné la mort après la
qualification andy ram mais a ordonné à
bord giresse et l'essentiel en est le
seul responsable et avoir transporté le
corps bon c'est déjà bien
on peut peut-être pas lui demander dans
la même heure et au goût de jaune garde
à vue sachant qui part en prison je ne
sais très bien mais pour connaître dans
le détail et notamment des détails les
plus atroces et la carbonisation donc si
c'est lui je conçois qu'il est pas
reconnue saad
l'un premier mouvement faut pas demander
tout comme tels ont été les mots comme
avant pas d'accablement pas de moi je ne
suis qu leur porte parole
on s'est entendu sur ce que je dirai je
dirais pas pas d'accablement pas de
l'ojectif contre lui c'est un garçon
constant ils faisaient partie de leur
famille c'est leurs jambes
il n'avait rien à lui reprocher ils ont
rien vu venir maintenant il faudrait
comprendre sur la qualification
à ce que je peux vous dire juridiquement
parlant c'est que ça ne sera pas ça
sinon ça sera pas assassinat parce que
dans cette affaire la soprano vraiment
rebondissements celui ci peut toujours
rêver il n'y a pas eu préméditation du
moins ce qu'on en sait aujourd'hui donc
ça sera pas assassinat ce que je peux
vous dire aussi c'est que c'est pas un
accident c'est certain donc meurtre sur
conjoint sommes parés pour l'instant
bien lu pénalement bien vu parce que ça
laisse une marge de manoeuvre c'est pas
un assassinat sauf rebondissement
imaginons qu'on apprenne demain que deux
puis trois mois et il avait un projet
criminel et que si que ça moi j'en sais
rien mais tout est possible en cfa mais
au jour d'aujourd'hui rien ne permet de
penser que c'est un assassinat
objectivement c'est pas un accident fait
raisonnable ah bah pourquoi parce que
comme monsieur d'aval sera passé à des
actes complémentaires et qui se
rapprochera de la réalité objective du
dossier on ne pourra que constater que
c'est tout sauf un de steam
il ya des éléments qui paraissait pas
l'action à bas un certain nombre de
pièces musicales sans rentrer dans cette
instruction
je vais faire comme la procureure y ait
un sens où on s'en va de soi mais c'est
pas l'accident
vous savez qu'un accident c'est jeu avec
le respect je dois je me dispute avec
vous je vous pousse ou tomber sur le
coin de la tam alors nous le coup et
fatale est bon grâce à ses coups ayant
entraîné la mort sans intention de
donner ils se connaissent et là c'est
pas ça du tout bon c'est une dispute
c'est une dispute violente qui a très
mal tourné la preuve d'excès morte ça
c'est sûr que je suis tout à fait à
korytza jusqu'à nouvel ordre c'est pas
prémédité ça peut changer mais pour
l'instant rien ne permet de le penser
mais après n'est pas tombé sur un coin
de table est mort sur le coup ne sais
pas ça donc est également sans aller
plus loin dans
à cause jusqu à l'instruction quand vous
ai trouvé quelqu'un déjà à manu que vous
voyez ses yeux à deux centimètres des
vôtres et beaucoup tous les deux c'est
vrai on peut pas dire que c'est un
accident
il faut être raisonnable aussi en termes
de sémantique vous dites que les menaces
ne veulent pas l'accabler pas ils sont
entendus le procureur ils savent qu'ils
encourent la perpétuité
ils ont près bien compris que les actes
qu'il a commis
feront dans le respect de la présomption
d'innocence qui sera certainement très
sévèrement condamnés mais que surtout la
comédie qu'il a joué peut-être à son
corps défendant
mais le rhabillage le la comédie la
comédie la comédie qu'il a joués kill
comédie mortel pour tout le monde lui
coûtera très cher dans l'esprit des
jurés que c'est ça qui fera peut-être la
différence un jour toujours en respect
d'après antonio sens entre 25 et 30 ans
la personnalité etc
ces créatures elle manque au pouvoir
monsieur regard des liens dans les
images en boucle qui circulaient
notamment sur les champs continuer sur
bfm en particulier c'est vrai qu'on
revoyait rétrospectivement les pleurs la
conférence de presse la marche blanche
où l'enterrement je rêve d'un anglais
aurait aucune raison que ça sera jugeons
de saône c'est très bien c'est d'un
dossier ou de surloyer restaurant de son
non non c'est très bien comme ça ne se
voyait aucune raison aucune raison à
vous entendre
on ne veut pas accabler leurs jambes
s'il n'est pas de ressentiment
finalement les beti des rations c'est
hier c'était l'effet de sidération sait
comment comment comment c'est possible
c'est même pas comment il a fait ça
c'est sais comment c'est comment c'est
possible
comment il pouvait y avoir faire une
tension plus importante et qu'on ne
l'ait pas vu parce que c'est comme ça
aussi
si il y avait forcément une tension plus
importante que celle qu'ils ont cru voir
ou pas voir sinon ils n'en seraient pas
il serait pas passé aux actes laissez
pas c'est pas loup garou jonathan donc
il ya une dispute forcément très
sérieuse
il ya eu des comportements forcément
qu'il a jugée abandonné insupportables
qu'ils ont fait ça c'est la théorie dite
de la cocotte-minute le psychiatre y
psychologie et qu'on fait que ce sage
garçon ce gendre idéal et bat totalement
pété les plombs et a commis
l'irréparable mais jamais ils m'ont vu
donc on avait des tensions c'est ce que
je disais tout à la détention comme dans
tous les couples mais rien de
symptomatique rien qu'il aurait pu qu'il
aurait permis par exemple de 10 rentrant
chez elle soir la suite d'un dîner a dit
non leur couple par exemple ne serait-ce
que ça j'ai peur qu'ils quittent ils
vont séparer ça va pas du tout ils vont
peut-être d'avancer même pas du tout à
l'heure à fortiori pas notre gendre
adoré va assassiner le freinerai n'ont
rien rien de rien d'alarmant rien qui
permet de tirer le signal d'alarmé
obtenir ne serait-ce un jour est posé la
question mais vous n'avez pas vu des
choses qui vous vous êtes pas dit pourvu
qu'ils dévorent sport parce qu'on les
aime bien pour utile c'est papa pas du
tout du tout ça va dans le couple savant
peu de tension pour le bain le gamin
mais savoureuse changement parler avec
les gens disent c'est surprenant qui
n'est pas de tout sur lui parce qu'à un
moment on peut estimer qu'ils ont été
pour nous tous alors il car il savait
qu'il y avait une rumeur qui est
constante
vous savez depuis le début en lisant
tout mon langues
ont dû dire dans vos milieux notre
milieu partout les eaux sociaux se
marient scénariste marine bon ça ils
n'ont pas pu y échapper au temps je
rappelle qu'ils ont un commerce très
exposés parce qu'ils ont un bar pmu
donc il voit quand même beaucoup de
monde dix ans temps ne sont pas autiste
mais ça n'a jamais au delà de ça parce
que la confiance étant tél premièrement
et puis deux n'ayant rien remarqué
d'alarmant dans le couple et aucune
raison qu'une atrocités comme ça vienne
de la part de quelqu'un ou qui on a
toute confiance et ça gérer c'est pas du
déni mais c'est presque du bon sens vous
avez quelqu'un vous avez jamais remarqué
chez votre fille non plus la tragédie à
rillieux ce garçon est léchée vous matin
midi et soir
il n'y a aucune saute d'humeur aucun
changement d'attitude
il est toujours aussi aimant l'égard des
beaux-parents de sa belle soeur et son
beau-frère aussi serviables aussi
correct il n'a pas d'accès des espoirs
andorre l'enterrement mais comme tout le
monde
bon pourquoi on croirait que ce type là
pu faire ça alors qu'on a confiance en
lui qu on n'a rien remarqué de larmor
c'est forcément dans ma famille c'est un
tiers c'est un voisin
c'est un client sais je sais pas moi
malade sexuel ne sais pas ça peut pas de
jeunes n'avaient rien remarqué
elle n'avait rien remarqué qu'ils
déploient qu'ils puissent être alarme et
elle elle pense et je le pensais que
c'était camille liesse des hommes
maternité et que ça devenait un petit
peu peut-être prise de tête chez les tic
et alexia bon
kittel prise de tête aussi pour jonathan
mais comme ces accords assez banal un
toussaint c'est alors je sais pas je ne
sais pas si c'était prévu mais ce que je
dis c'est que c'est bien ce n'est pas eu
lieu parce que d'abord c'est pas
l'endroit ça viendra au procès d'assises
et ça aurait été je crois pour tout le
monde une épreuve assez insoutenable et
pour mes clients et consommateurs qui a
déjà on va dire forte à faire avec
l'avenir judiciaire qui lui irait
service il ya comme une petite musique
pendant un petit peu depuis hier soir
comme si le carré d'herbe dominateurs
ont donné que ça pouvait être avec
énormément guillemette des sortes de
circonstances atténuantes
ça ne peut jamais être une circonstance
atténuante mais ça peut une situation
peut permettre notamment devant la cour
d'assises de comprendre le passage à
l'acte mais ça peut jamais être une
circonstance atténuante la mort d'une
personne dans des conditions tragiques
ne peut pas trouver des circonstances
atténuantes moins pas dans ce cas là
simplement ça peut faire partie ça sera
très utile pour comprendre le contexte
leur vie de couple intime que finalement
personne ne connaissait pas ce que pour
faire simple personne à part eux deux
savaient que la tension était beaucoup
plus lourd beaucoup visiblement beaucoup
plus graves que ce qu'ils ont laissé
paraître l'égard de leurs familles
respectives et ça sera tout l'intérêt
des expertises psychologiques et
psychiatriques psychiatrique je pense
pas que ça donnerait grand chose que
monsieur d'avaler normalement à mon avis
d'une normalité absolue mais par contre
sur le plan psychologique ça serait
intéressant de connaître son passé sa
construction savez que c'est ça
l'essentiel son enfance qu'est ce qui a
fait alors qu'il aimait sa femme
personne n'en doute qu'il est passé à
l'acte et dans des conditions atroces et
puis qu'après il a enchaîné tous les
mauvais réflexes parce qu'il aurait plus
disputé avec sa femme sa tour on le
comprend ça aurait pu très mal tourner
c'est affreux mais ça arrive c'est ici
les et les magazines bon et en gros
trois chaînes par jour donc ça arrive
même chez des gens très bien mais
comment après ce jean qui garçons de ce
singe garçon qui a un téléphone qui peut
appeler le médecin c'est peut-être parce
éléments le médecin les pompiers police
gendarmerie sa belle famille qui est à
200 m ses frères ses parents ou qui sont
à côté
comment ce garçon que rien ne prédestine
à saint et qui a pas de double
personnalité
comment il peut se lancer dans ce jeu
déshabille la femme j'ai un bioshock 2
je la mets dans je sais pas quoi dans un
grand flash ignore jeu la transporte au
fin fond de la nuit sans éclairage
chauffe mesfar dans les bois ensuite
qu'est ce qui se passera on sait qu'ils
avaient brûlé peut-être pas par lui mais
enfin j'en sais rien mais comment on
fera les bassins et puis le lendemain
j'appelle les gendarmes sur un petit
matinée comme si de rien n'était le
papier jeunes visiblement pas ce que
j'appelle les gendarmes commencent à
dire je m'inquiète qui givet puis deux
puis trois mois je suis le trois mois je
fais le sait pas quels mots employer
je fais le veuf éploré que je suis
certain nous mais je n'arrive pas à
trouver un moment pour dire les choses
j'ai passé ça qui est incompréhensible
c'est un gars comme lui soit j'en sais
rien mais oui bien si c'est pas lui
c'est qui pour les violences et le seul
à témoigner de ces violences dans leur
couple donc si personne ne travaille
plus il n'y a aucun témoin qui a pu dire
qu'il y avait des violences auxquelles
elle était venue
alors ça je pense que c'était et c'est
toujours pareil vous savez il ya
beaucoup de témoins qui ont été entendus
à l'origine dans cette affaire-là
quand vous témoigner pour la marque rage
il alexis avec vous la connaissez la
première chose qui vous vient à l'esprit
un témoignage c'est peut-être pas de
dire elle était comme ci comme ça avec
son mari c'est plutôt de la compassion
pour la victime ce qui est normal je
pense que maintenant que les choses sont
posés en ce qui concerne la taille même
si encore du boulot sur la route de la
vérité je pense qu'il aura peut-être un
certain nombre de personnes qui seront
réentendus et qui ayant entendu ce qui
est dû notamment aux médecins torpeur il
leur reviendra peut-être l'esprit des
scènes des détails ou des éléments de
disputes j'en sais rien on aura
peut-être plus de matériel de ce côté là
mais d'un autre côté vous avez aussi des
couples et vous le savez c'est souvent
le cas dans les violences
quelle qu'en soit l'auteur et qu'elle
conçoit la victime ou à l'extérieur on
est parfait de notre boulot n'est
parfait dans ma belle famille on est
parfait partout et puis quand on est
chez soi ce n'est pas la même donc ça
personne tient la chandelle mais ça on
le connaît ce couple est là reconnaît
donc il ya aussi cette difficulté la
dernière conférence de presse
évoquer un possible lien avec alors je
suis prêt je ne veux pas persécutés un
concours ça mais j'ai toujours comme
cette histoire là sous le coude j'ai
toujours cette histoire est cool et moi
je suis comme saint thomas je crois ce
que je vois je n'ai pas accès au dossier
du suicide et des moulins en plus un
suicide n'y a pas de juge d'instruction
à rien et un dossier au parquet qui doit
pas être pressé paix mais je sais que
nos deux pays à des tests adn
comparative le jour mort a dit j'ai pas
besoin de voir le test que on a prélevé
l'adn du défunt des moulins et qu'on la
compare avec les adn retrouvés sur la
scène de crime et que l'on peut circuler
à un avoir
on parlera plus des moulins mais tant
que ces résultats sont pas connues et
bains et dans les draps je n'aurais
ferme pas pour moi cette case voilà
est-ce que c'est à dire qu'il ya des adn
inconnus sur la scène de crime
bah ya beaucoup d' adn et naturellement
on peut on ne peut élucider les adn vous
le savez que d'une part si on a un
matériel de comparaison avec les
écouvillon c'est les personnes prélevées
ou si par chance on n'a pas prélevées
mais que la personne est déjà dense
notamment dans un autre fichier mais
essentiellement au flag
donc c'est intéressant d'abraham à un
écouvillon de plus ce séjour est bien
que ce soit l'écouvillon du deffand des
semis
je les banques quand j'ai pas mangé ou
bénir et tous les jours aucun changement
il aurait demandé aucun changement voire
même mon camp un rapprochement depuis la
mort d'alexis un entregent natale et ses
beaux-parents et sa belle soeur et son
beau frère que je représente
non c'est un garçon c'était un garçon
parfait
c'est un élément lié à ce que je vais
vous dire va peut-être choquer j'en sais
rien je pense que oui c'est le réalisme
de maîtres chiens d'enfer et son
professionnalisme
moi j'aurais fait pareil si j'avais été
à sa place c'est acquis à un moment
quand vous avez la conviction que votre
client a commis des choses très graves
mais la conviction son saoul mais
surtout que vous avez façon dans votre
dossier des éléments objectifs de
culpabilité il ya deux stratégies ça il
a très bien expliqué angel sur barrière
il ya des confrères qui vont vous dire
moi je continue de vous dire que ça
c'est pas un bar ça c'est pas une tape
ça c'est pas un micro posé les mange
m'en fous et secousses mon client a nié
jusqu'au bout et ne vous n'avez jamais
c'est la théorie de landre montée sera
guillotiné dit n'avoir jamais bon ça
c'est contre-productive et à mon avis
c'est même contraire totalement au
serment qu on a prêté à nos valeurs et
puis les confrères qui ont la même
philosophie où je parte à celle de
mathieu dorfer les piliers vous le savez
c'est pas c'est pas un scoop et qu'ils
fassent des éléments objectifs grave de
culpabilité qui ne peuvent qu'aller vers
des choses tragiques devant la cour
d'assises prennent leurs clients entre
quatre yeux et leur disent oui mais deux
solutions vous l'avez fait moi je porte
pas de jugement vous avez fait parce que
au plus vrai plus et comptait alors ni
et ça vous allez vous faire beaucoup de
mal et vous reconstruirez jamais vous
allez encore faire beaucoup de mal à vos
beaux parents adorés pour le respect de
la mémoire de votre femme nous doute pas
vous l'aimiez pensez-y
et puis pensez à la cour d'assises il ya
la claque qui vous
et la différence sera peut-être cinq ans
debout alors moi je vous dis je vous dis
et vous en faites ce que vous voulez
avoué ce que vous voulez mais avouez et
je pensais ce qui a fait la différence
parce que monsieur dauphin quelqu'un de
convaincu comme parce que c'est un
professionnel et j'en attends est un
garçon obéissons et je pense que c'est
la différence me serais tombé sur un
confrère qui leur ai dit jonathan ne dit
rien on n'aurait pas d'amis ils ne
seraient pas non c'est moi c'est mon
sentiment c'est mon sentiment parce que
vous avez vu que les amuse arrive en fin
de garde à vue ils sont quand même pas
spontanée mais bon ça s'explique aussi
quand vous avez ça sur l'estomac
c'est parfois dur à sortir et je pense
que vous avez vu les communiqués
lemercier en dorfer elle-même spatafora
au cours de la journée
nous sommes mis en difficulté des
éléments sont très difficiles 8e terme
accablant une série quoi il parle
et à partir de là je ne doute pas qu'il
est convaincu jonathan de libérer sa
conscience et je pense la toute dernière
heure de la garde à vue c'est ce qu'a
fait différent je peux me tromper un
moule je suis à peu près persuadé
notamment l'assemblée choqué en tout cas
pas du tout non je crois que ça leur a
même moi ça m'a facilité la tâche que ça
leur a permis progressivement au cours
des journées de se dire ça va être lui
le pire va arriver une deuxième fois on
va perdre un deuxième membre de la
famille ça va être jonathan c'est
impensable
incroyable je suis pas ce qui a pu
arriver mais il va falloir se rendre à
l'évidence et ça je crois que c'est moi
ça m'aide ça m'aide aussi
alors vous savez après les critiques
entendues hier sur les plateaux parisien
des confrères je citerai pas pontifier
sur ce qu'il faut faire
pas faire vous connaissez pas le dit
connaissent pas le dossier wassa y voit
ça à froid ils sont pas dans la garde à
vue
giresse qui l'on pense peu me chaut moi
je que je vois c'est que maître chien
blanc ferait il a été efficace
et quand il va vous dire c'est quelqu'un
qui est pas son client était maltraitée
psychologiquement et peut-être
physiquement et il a dégoupillé ingé pas
lui répondre j'entends ce qu'il dit
j'entends ce qui est dit savez le procès
il n'arrivera pas au mieux avant le
premier semestre 2010 9
il ya du chemin à parcourir on verra à
partir de là quel est le positionnement
de monsieur d'aval qu'est ce qu'il dit
sur ce sujet qui est intéressant qui
pour rien justifiée en rien être une
circonstance atténuante ça va de soi
mais qui peut expliquer un contexte que
tout le monde sera intéressé d'apprendre
parce que perso tout le monde ignore à
ce jour eh ben on verra mais à ce moment
là mais pour l'instant contentons nous
de ce que nous sommes déjà c'est à dire
beaucoup
un coupable qui a priori est le bon dans
le respect de la présomption d'innocence
et qui a avoué l'essentiel après même
s'il ya beaucoup de choses encore à
revoir mais qui est quand même bien
moins de courage de dire ce qu'on
attendait c'est déjà bien ne soyons pas
trop impatients
maintenant il ya en gros un ans
d'instruction c'est 2018 et à procès
programmé devant la cour d'assises de la
haute saône siégeant à vesoul
probablement fin
premier semestre début du deuxième
semestre 2010